[Music]
now today for our daily cancellation i'm
afraid that we must go
once again and plunge the depraved
depths
of the cyber sewage dump known as
tick-tock
i've been accused of leaning too heavily
on tick-tock for my cancellations
but first of all again mind your own
business second of all
there's there's just a lot of
intentionally unintentionally not
intentionally but unintentionally
hilarious stuff there and third
this is the app that the kids are using
and being influenced by so at a certain
point we have to stop
with this really kind of foolish thing
of acting like
the content that our kids not my kids
but a lot of people's kids spend hours a
day ingesting is somehow frivolous and
unimportant
it may be stupid it may be embarrassing
but it's not frivolous because
because it's what's helping to shape the
next generation for better or worse
and in this case worse with that said we
have to cancel a guy named ryan
mccarten um or ryan mccarron one of the
two
anyway he has a huge following on tick
tock and apparently he's an actor
or something and uh there's one video in
particular that puts him in line to be
canceled today
but going through his catalog as i did
it seems that
many tick tock users come to him for
advice and wisdom
and he's eager to offer it so as an
example of that here's a here's a recent
video
where he gives his mind-blowing totally
unique perspective
on the abortion debate you're not going
to believe this listen
so there are three parts of this
conversation to me the science of
abortion the history abortion and the
debate about abortion i want to talk
about the debate right now but let me
know if you want to hear the other stuff
the debate about abortion is are you
pro-choice or pro-life and that just
sets up a false dichotomy
because the opposite of pro-life is
anti-life no one is anti-life and we
aren't actually talking about life we're
talking about birth so then the debate
would be pro-birth or anti-birth and
that doesn't make any sense either
so you go back to our original terms
choice i think that's what the debate is
about are you pro-choice or are you
anti-choice and the thing that just
really bothers me about this argument a
is that liberals have
succumbed to this idea of arguing with a
pro-life stance when we're not talking
about life we're talking about choice
but also the conservative thinking in
america is all about limiting government
to not
step in on our individual liberties to
make our own choices about our lives so
i don't understand why liberals and
conservatives aren't actually on the
same page about this the government
should not make any choices about what
we do with our individual liberties
regarding our own bodies no matter who
we are what we look like or what our
bodies do
wow wow just incredible
so so so he he wants to let me see if i
got this correctly
he wants to reframe the debate as
pro-choice or anti-choice
i have never heard that before i mean
this this has completely altered the way
i view this issue
i have simply never heard someone make
the anti-choice point before
it's it's amazing i mean no one's ever
said this that's why this guy's so proud
of himself
when he makes this point you know i've
been thinking about this i think
this is about choice huh
this man is a philosopher for the ages
if socrates came across this guy
socrates would poison himself again just
because he's so depressed
that he'll never be as smart and
insightful as ryan mccarten
or mccarran all that said yes
actually the issue is about life the
fundamental question is whether the baby
in the womb is a human life and whether
as a human life it has the same moral
worth
and is therefore entitled to the same
legal protections as
a born person now i say yes if ryan
mccartney says no
he should explain why his answer is no
but people on the anti-life side rarely
want to defend that part of their
argument
now as for the government not telling us
what to do with our bodies well okay
then
so i assume you're an avid anti-massacre
in that case
that's the government telling you what
to do with your with your body oh but
that's different you say it's different
because
if you don't wear a mask you could harm
somebody else
ah okay so so you can do what you want
with your body
up to the point where you're potentially
inflicting harm on another person
hmm well the unborn
human who is poisoned dismembered or
decapitated
through the course of the abortion would
you say that qualifies as
harm oh but that's different you say
because the unborn human
doesn't count well what do you know
we're right back to a debate about life
in its definition
which is exactly what you said the
debate is not about but it turns out
that is what the debate is always about
it can't be about
anything else so that's ryan mccartney
on abortion
now let's hear what he has to say about
racism
i am the oppressor i am racist oh my god
he just said he's racist
it shouldn't be this hard you guys if
you live in america
went to school participate in the
socioeconomic structures participate in
any sort of system
education business entertainment what
have you and you are white
you are indoctrinated you are oppressive
and yes you are racist it is something
that we have
learned either consciously or
subconsciously all of us as white
americans
and what we have to do is unlearn that
i'm trying to do the work
part of doing the work is pushing
against dangerous narratives that are
counter-intuitive to that unlearning
like
white people are also oppressed by
racism we're not
we are the oppressors that's the point
you should be doing the unlearning too
do the work i love this guy's dance
moves
choreography while he makes his point i
don't know what all this you can't see
it if you're listening to audio podcasts
but he's got a certain move that he does
he's like it's like it's like watching
in sync or something in the 90s
it's all the all the choreography but um
first of all if i live my whole life and
never again hear the phrase
do the work from somebody who does not
appear to have ever done
any kind of work at all in their lives i
will die a happy man second
i'm not gonna spend a lot of time
debunking this notion that only white
people are racist because
only they have systemic power yada yada
et cetera
i've addressed that many times and as
i've explained it is built on numerous
false assertions starting with the idea
that power has anything necessarily to
do with racism
and also the idea that only white people
have systemic power
we can look around right now and see
every major corporation bending over
backwards to affirm the most radical
tenets
of blm orthodoxy we could see that the
same is true of politicians and
bureaucrats and
almost everybody who wields serious
power in this country we can also see
that
the only form of explicit racial
systemic bias
that's allowed in this country is the
kind that cuts against white people like
affirmative action
all of that is clear so this from ryan
mccarten and those like him
is nothing but a doctrinal statement
it's not based on any kind of evidence
or logic
except an internal logic within the
critical race theory cult
and even there internally there isn't
much logic to it
just remember anytime somebody says only
white people can be racist
all you have to do is respond with one
question this is what i would respond
with
says who oh only white people can be
racist
okay says who who says that
you do but where are you getting that
from why should i accept
your definition of racism i understand
that that's your claim that's your
belief but
why should i give a damn why should i
believe it
and i guess if you want to follow up
with another question you could also ask
this did racism exist
a thousand years ago two thousand years
ago three thousand years did it exist in
ancient times
did racism exist back when people were
slaughtering and enslaving outsiders
just as a matter of course
because because if if racism is inherent
to white people because of their
systemic power then it must mean that
racism didn't exist before white people
as we know them now
existed or before they had this kind of
power i mean i mean you go back through
history and um
you find that the most powerful empires
back in ancient times were in places
like egypt and mesopotamia
was there no racism then was it an
anti-racist utopia which just so
happened to subsist on slavery and
conquest
so that's a question you could ask but
what i want to focus on
is uh is something else at a deeper
level is the guilt
you know i've long suspected that one of
the things that makes this all white
people a racist idea appealing
is the way that it explains and channels
guilt
now for non-white people the appeal is
pretty straightforward they're absolved
of racism permanently
and they're positioned as the automatic
good guy in any dispute with a white
person
that's a hell of a deal if you can get
it but for white people part of the
appeal i think is is religious in nature
what is it that that will often times
you think about what what will
oftentimes get a person to go to church
after a long time away they're feeling
burdened
by their sin feeling guilty they're
looking for absolution for something
they want something to do with this
guilt that they're carrying around
but with theistic religion receding and
with many of the remaining churches too
afraid to talk about guilt and sin
anyway
things like critical race theory step
into the gap
jesus says come to me all who are
burdened and i will give you rest
well those who are burdened and not
going to jesus have to go somewhere else
crt critical race theory is a substitute
for some people only it's not going to
offer rest or absolution instead it just
offers more guilt but at least
it explains and clarifies the guilt or
claims to
it puts everything in racial terms and
gives confused and desperate people
a framework for understanding themselves
and their own
internal struggles the framework is
wrong and evil
but hey at least it's a framework to
paraphrase
the big lebowski all that said
the the other possible explanation
so i mean all that just maybe that's why
if i want to go to a real deep
like psychological philosophical level
uh maybe that's why someone like ryan
mccarthy
is so eager to call himself racist
maybe the other possible explanation for
why ryan mccarthy says he's racist
is that he's actually racist i mean that
is what he's saying maybe we should just
take him seriously
maybe when a white person gets up and
says i'm racist
we should just say oh okay well sorry to
hear about that
and then when he says yeah but all of
you are too we we say not me
i don't know man speak for yourself uh
you already said it you've
you've co you've made your claim i i'm
not joining you i'm i'm not giving you
any cover
here so hate to hear about that i'm
sorry
shouldn't be racist that sucks man i
have
you know thanks for telling us
just because you are doesn't mean that i
am ryan speak for yourself
and maybe in the end maybe maybe that is
the one
needed response to the critical race
theory cultist
speak for yourself also
you're canceled so those two things well
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content